started thanks for coming to the last
day of the last workshop so just to
bring everybody back to where we are
so in this workshop we were talking
about a lot of things that we didn't
really cover in this program or any
other workshops and they're kind of
things that need a lot of work and so we
have two talks on a trip in ability so
Julius and then bean bean we heard from
earlier this summer anyone have one
robustness talk and one RL talk today as
well so thank you clarify that you will
not be seen any deep theorems so you can
and so so we'll be talking about
explanations and almost every talk about
interpretability explanations you define
what you mean by
I won't be giving you some insightful
new definition of intelligibility this
talk actually is trying to see sort of
make it more to see how we can evaluate
explanation methods and so if you why do
we tend to one explanation
oh you don't necessarily senses that a
lot of people tend to expand
explanations cause all in some sense so
to give you explanations for this talk
you can think of it as some artifacts
that we'll be able to get from some
model predictive models in this case
very fact that will try and provide
insights that you'll learn about and if
you're not you know satisfied with the
sort of
and so I wanted to I was in preparing
for this talk I was trying to get a
sense for papers in this areas this is
definitely not an order alternative
figure it's inspired by this same figure
and it's interesting that you can see
like a jump in but there's definitely a
lot of work in this area and I will
definitely now cover most of it actually
this would be a very tiny slice of some
of the work in this area so you should
keep that in mind as you so why would we
care about explanation so there's a
paper challenges and interpretability
there's for transparency touches on a
lot of the points you might be
interested one could be a model a
toboggan and that's the one would that
would inspire a lot of the work a lot of
and you can think about it as let's say
you have some new architecture develop
decided you've trained this model and
you want to get a sense for when is this
model going to make mistakes I'm very
interested in trying to figure that out
another one could be safety concerns
yesterday there was a session s you
could potentially imagine hypothetically
that you could have explorations that
you derive for a model that give you
insight into another one there's also
very interested in is as humans we tend
to be very interested in especially for
systems that were interact with on a
daily basis form of artifacts that would
sort of satiate our trust or try and say
this is why this this is why I'm getting
this recommendation on Amazon this is
what I'm getting this recommendation for
this movie so these are some general
high-level motivation there are
definitely orders that you can think of
and you could definitely also say that
maybe explanations might not necessarily
the right framework to try and attack
those problems but in general this tends
to be so to focus on the model debugging
frame working here familiar with this
literature you might have seen this
example before so in terms of debugging
so debugging can be a very vague term
here we here's an example that's trying
to sort of illustrate that this is from
a paper in 2016 there there's very
interesting example that sort of capture
you have this this image that's
classified as a wolf
and you can then ask for some kind of
explanation we'll get into what an
explanation and when you ask for that
explanation so there's a gray it has
great a bunch of things out but it's
sort of highlighting the snow so this
white background and if you look at that
image you can say oh perhaps my model is
not it's not learning the interesting
thing that I wanted to learn about this
focusing on the snow which you might say
shouldn't necessarily be reflective of
whether something is a wolf or not so
this could be some kind of artifacts you
want to reveal as part of your training
process that you want an explanation to
I did yes do you believe any part of
that story like do you believe that it's
focusing on anything anything on this
slide tells you even can I defer that
question to let say 3/4 of the way into
the presentation and we'll try and sort
of that's part of it so that's one of
the things we actually want to learn in
this presentation how true is it that we
can learn those artifacts but we'll get
to that point so another interesting
interest you might have is let's say so
this is a data set that was released
earlier
here at all and it was a bunch of faces
so it's called diversity and faces
intersect and there's a bunch of
different face faces so let's say you
live in I guess maybe
and you I mean when you were collecting
this data you sort of mislabeled a
particular subset of this data points
you train a a model on this you might
necessarily want a model you might want
an interpreter bility met or an
expedition method that would say this is
a subset of my my training points that
my model
misbehaviour potential interest you
might have to say I don't so understand
what I'm always doing
so that's another motivation for why you
might want to look at explorations and
so to sort of make it more I guess still
high level but concrete so you train a
model it tells you this thin as a husky
even though it's looking at you say it's
looking at the snow part of the image
and then I pathetically you could say oh
this is a kind of thing I don't want to
fix about our models so this loop of
I've trained a model and the model has
learned some spurious correlation in my
data set now I want to fix this for
escalation this is one big interest you
might you might have I'm sure you've
seen all of the examples from the
medical literature where a model see an
entrance of images happens to learn
something was a particular type of
scanner that was being this kind of
spurious correlation is something you
might want to prevent an especially
identify before you even deploy tomorrow
and so this sort of model debugging
promise that a lot of explanations have
is something that I think is very
interesting and that's sort of the big
motivation for a lot of a lot of the
work we'll be talking about
is there any model that you would say
confidently any CNN trained for any
image tops that you would say
confidently is learning something that
couldn't recently described as spurious
correlation you could say it's learning
the wrong thing is there anything
there's nothing the wrong frame work in
the first place and then I think that
I'm not sure I can give an answer
trapped because it's a very broad it's a
very broad question that it's not I'm
not sure I can give a definite answer to
that maybe after we can talk but I but
that's a very good question and and so
before going on I wanted to sort of give
a difference between what you might call
interpretability versus expeditions and
so interpretability tends to sort of
refer to when you constrain the model
class you're learning from why when you
constraint in a sense that let's say I
say I want an interpretable model and
this is this is definitely a very vague
term in the sand in their centers that
I'm using but you could say if I learn a
bunch of if-then rules and if ten rules
are not necessarily too long then
perhaps somebody can look at this
if-then rules and understand them but
interpretability tends to refer to when
you constrain them up so for example you
could say this is the difference between
learning a lasso model versus and you're
looking at the weights of a lasso model
versus you saying I get you or you're
flexible and the way you learn your
model and then I'm going to come back
come in with a post-hoc method to
interpret it in concern
explaining the model and designing a
model and how common is this distinction
partitioning to this we know so I mean
this is not my terminal this is emergent
and maybe the the the answer comes from
comes from here which is that there's a
lot of work recently that's been focused
on post hoc interpretations and then
another spectrum of this could be what I
mentioned I might want to sort of say
use only linear models use a decision
tree that's a good point so I'm taking
it from from sort of st. here's language
and I think it tends to because I
actually think it's a very big
difference between the two approaches
and it's you need some sort of
terminology it's a differentiate I think
it's used interchangeably and it's not
clearly defined or a consensus in the
community but they're just paper that's
kind of I think modulators they might
tell you what to do
maybe there's like need for better
terminology because using outsider to
the field very well I would not have
expect that's why I'm using it here and
I'm trying to say I'm the point of me
doing that is trying to say you a lot of
the conclusions you will take away from
this talk don't apply to vastly across
the field they just apply it's a very
narrow slice of the pie and so that
difference and the terminology is
helpful in this presentation and so I
also think the perspective that she
offers those and the perspective she
offers in and her paper is actually a
very interesting one and if you have
some time you should in this talk will
actually focus on post hoc local
explanations and so I will try and give
some yes so it's a local vertical view
kind of another way to separate these
yeah I will I will get to that part I'm
still sort of setting things up here and
so as everyone here knows you can you
can train your favorite and here because
we'll be looking at a lot of gradients
that's why I'm sort of specifying this
so you can say it's going from our D to
our C C's the number of classes you have
and then DS the size of your input so
one kind of explanation you can imagine
it would be a sensitivity map and so
what that is here is so you have that
input and you've trained a bunch you
trained your favorite model on the same
point so now you can look at the
gradient of class score with respect to
the input and so what this is saying is
there's a class corn there and then
you're now looking at the
gradient of that scalar with respect to
the input which is a vector the size of
your input and then you can visualize
this and I should also point out the
choice of the visualization is also very
visualization is actually what and you
can surely say get to that point as well
and so this sort of gradient explanation
would be the fundamental sort of kernel
a lot of the methods ok and here the
reason why this might be interested in
is if you think of a single in your
linear model if you do this gradient so
let's say that a single output if you do
the gradient that gives you the weights
of that model and then in some sense
that's sort of what you would expect as
that's why this is also interesting and
it also conveys this notion that a lot
of people are comfortable with which is
the fact that if I change some pixel by
a little amount how much does that shape
output and so you can get
of course so this was sort of introduce
the notion of using the gradient as
interpretation goes back a long time but
in this context was introduced in this
favorite scene there are the references
as well another notion of interpret
explanations that we'll look at in this
work is examples or sort of prototypes
that you can represent what the network
is doing so in this case let's say you
train the model on cats and dog and then
you have a new test point so the image
on the far left is a new test point you
have you can then ask the question can
you rank all of the training points
based on their influence on the test
loss and so this is you might have seen
a work for mice and all 2017 unless
using influence functions to rank the
influence example you can also do this
in other ways as well and that's what
the so here the interpretation you have
the explanation you get is you have a
test point and then you return the top K
training points in this case is three
training points that have the most
effect on the test so that's another
kind of explanation you can have I so
those will be the two kinds we'll look
at in this work mostly the first but
this would also come into play when we
meaning doesn't mean that if you if you
had remove these from the training set
then the classification of that test
point would
change of love lots of good change
the most significant okay so local
explanations so there's another
dimension you can use to group the kinds
of explanations work that is emergent in
this area which is there's local versus
global view and so why might this be an
attractive thing so if you're in a
linear set in as I mean this would be
obvious linear setting then you just
have this weight vector and that weight
vector tells you what you're doing with
any point in a nonlinear setting of
course it's nonlinear where you are in
your in the input space things change
and you can change dramatically and this
is the motivation for a lot of the work
that has focused on local explanations
and one kind that's very popular would
be I will if I want to give an
explanation for a particular input I
will fit some local model later around
that particular input and then I will
interpret this model as a way to sort of
so that's why the local explanations
point is you this nice interpretation
that you can sort of approximate your
model around single inputs and well
actually this is one of the things with
my challenge in this talk whether this
is desirable
there are ways to get around some of the
problems you might have so this is the
this is one of the inspiration for why
you want to do this and so the four sort
of going into the actual meat of the
presentation the key takeaways and so
your first one is it's actually very
difficult to assess a lot of this look
or explanation members and the reason
why you'd want to assess them is that it
seems like we're moving to a place where
explanations or the desire for
explanations are the things we'll rely
on before we deploy them all so you want
to rely on explanations then the
explanations themselves better reflect
so you might want a sense for how well
is the explanation really reflecting the
second part is so the first part would
be some work from last year the second
part would be ongoing still planaria
work which is that from a privacy
perspective let's say you're a start-up
and you built your you build sort of a
model to sort of diagnose some kind of
some kind of let's say you you're
predicting cancer from a bunch of
different images and you've spent a lot
of money and you've hired a lot of
developers to develop this model and now
you'll licensing your model to let's say
a hospital so the hospital can say here
a bunch of test images can you give us
your predictions
and or explanations on those test images
as well
and if you do this it's actually very
easy to recover the model that you spent
a lot of money so there seems to be this
privacy and will define what privacy
will be it'll be sort of privacy kind of
so this seems to be this privacy versus
explanations tension which is you might
want to explain your model so you might
want to say here is in a sense some
insights you can learn from this model
that I've built but then as you start to
explain the model you run into trouble
because it's very easy to recover the
model on for somebody to this will be
the the big trade-offs would be that
perhaps local explanations are maybe we
should sort of try and rethink how we
use local solutions in this for example
the method area the ranks the training
points if as we all know your training
data is is a really key part of your
pipeline if you show people you're
ranking of your training points if
you're very careful with the way you
choose the queries you ask up a model
you can very easily recover that was
used to build a model and so these are
some of the trade-offs
and so let's talk about the first one
and so you've already seen this so
there's an input and then you give a
prediction you can look at the gradient
which would be the gradient of some
class core which corn in this is just
the inputs you get something like this
why is this this is also very one of the
reasons why this is attractive is
because packages this is one line and
it's so it's very easy to just and so
there's another method there are other
methods and so why would you want other
methods one potential reason why you
want other methods is when you train you
know the gradient tends to saturate and
so it's actually not clear when you do
this derivatives sometimes it's not
clear what your what the visual
representation is and from a visual
perspective it tends to look noisy
that's a little that's a phrase you've
seen a lot of papers to describe what
you get from looking at this grade and
so this motivation inspired a lot of
future work one of them is for grant and
what snow grad doors is you perturb your
input with Gaussian noise and then you
take this gradients and average them and
it's very well but when you visually
look at smooth grad it might seem to you
late starting to capture a lot of weight
so in that with corn it seems like
- imagine you can translate the smoke
raft picture onto the original image it
seems like it's highlighting the way to
corners there's another method called
integrated gradients and was actually
also has a lot of nice properties which
is you so what this does is you have a
baseline inputs and your baseline is
supposed to capture in some sense zero
so it's supposed to capture when your
model is not really doing anything with
respect and then this method sort of
computes a path integral from the
baseline all the way to the original
input and then you sum that and the one
nice prophecy this has is the
attribution you have to each dimension
sums up to the final others and so this
is a completeness property so this is
another kind of gradient based
explanation we can we can probably spend
the whole of this workshop going through
these are a few different ones you don't
necessarily have to try and figure out
what I'm talking about
gradient smooth grad and integrative
gradients well there are several
different versions and this actually
doesn't necessarily these are some of
the popular ones that people tend to use
in the literature but there's definitely
several others and I've added the edge
detector here you can ignore it for now
but we'll get
and so their broad classes of this
explanation methods some of them when
you compute the gradient then modify the
rules so they might say something like
as you're doing this matrix
multiplication all the way back to input
you should zero out negative activations
or you should negative gradients or
there are different rules about how you
should in another case lime is a
technique that will fit it tends to be a
local linear model around a single input
and then the weights of that model would
is something you would use as your
explanation and so so this is sort of
the survey of the of the last year and
their order techniques as well that can
so this slide is supposed to show you
that there are different ways you can
visualize those things and then there
are also different ways you can learn
that so for example you could say when
I'm trying to fit a local model around
my input I want to sort of satisfy some
properties so you can say that once you
remove a patch from this image and I
want I wanted to say I wanted I want
that patch to be small but I also want
so that when I removed that patch the
probability of this image in corn
increases and so that's another way in
which you could learn a model and you
could visualize it this way so that's
sort of broad survey of the kinds of
explanations you could have in this in
this
and you could actually use them to do
interesting things so this is a paper
from PNAS this year where they've used
integrated greedy ins to analyze it so
here there's a they're different malik
the other data set with different
molecules and this values by a specific
protein and depending on the bond so I'm
not a chemistry major but depending on
the bonds you have that would I would
sort of affect the affinity of the
molecules in finances in this work they
built a model to predict binding and
then you can attribute the bonds and so
red and blue here are telling you so you
can and so the point of this is to say I
love this techniques have been used in
very different settings
and so the first challenge we have is if
you so let's say you're very interested
in this area and you've trained your
favorite now you say okay I want to
explain my model the first challenge
when you have is how do you pick among
all of these different methods which one
to use and which one of them seems like
it's because they they all from they all
seem visually different in some sense so
which one of them captures what the
model is doing so that's the first
challenge and so the first part of this
talk would be trying to assess this and
so about how this assessment was done
previously and so one way you might want
to use to assess this this a lot of
these methods give you a ranking and
then you would say okay I will take the
top 10% of the dimensions
I never remove those and then see how
much my prediction changes and you can
do this for all of your features and
then draw what looks like a like an ROC
curve and then take the area under this
curve and take that as a measure of how
well another another popular way would
be to one of those localizations a so
or anything assembly of the truth on
their boxes or on objects so you train
on them on a task like this and then you
say how much does my heatmap localize
inside of this box so these are some of
the first way of evaluating yeah if we
don't define what is the purpose of
evaluation I don't see the point of
discussing different types of
evaluations I will I will get to that
point I end of at the end of this I can
come back to you and and so these are
two current ways that people interpret
sort of do ranking for this method and
so this is where our first work comes in
so he wanted to and remember we're
coming from this model sort of debugging
perspective we use a lot of heat maps to
try and understand what kind of mistakes
so this is joint work so be nice here
this is joint work with those people so
Justin Michael and Morrison
and so the inspiration for this you
might have seen some of this before the
inspiration for this was we're going to
have two checks one of them will call a
model randomization test the other one
will call data randomization test and so
one possible desirable property of that
would be if I mess up my model so let's
say I randomize the weights of my model
how well is this out what is the change
in the explanation map that I get so
presumably if an explanation map
captures something about what the
concept this map captures what it means
for that image to be a corn even if I
change the if I randomize the model so
that's not predicting corn anymore how
much does my that's the that's the kind
of property that this and so we can do
this for a lot of different methods and
the option of this is there are some
methods that regardless of the so in
this case what we're actually doing is
reinitializing the parameters of the
network so here this is Inception v3 and
on the Left far left you're starting
from the top layer I'm going all the way
to the bottom there so you randomized
you reinitialize all of the weights
starting from the top layer all of the
rational parameters or the biases all
the way to the first layer and for some
methods what we notice is so in
particular guided back propagation for
some methods what we notice is
regardless of change to the network in
parameters we don't observe we can
quantify this with a quantitative right
and so that's what you should take away
from this I told you that you can
visualize this things in different ways
so here this visualization is
essentially showing you what parts of
the image were most important regardless
of science so if you computer gradient
you have some negative and some positive
gradient so here this absolute value so
we're taking the absolute values of
those gradients you can also look at if
I actually visualize completely random
yes so this is if you visualize the
positive and negative grades it can be a
little bit difficult to see what's going
on so we we in in the paper we add some
quantitative metrics that we looked at
so we looked at so this is two of them
so you can compute rank correlation so a
lot of this gradient explanation mask
that will actually have a score for each
dimension and then you can compute a
rank correlation between the explanation
you get for the original model and the
one of the randomized power correlation
without absolute values with absolute
values from here is there some methods
even in both cases don't change and the
another interesting thing is when you
realize the signs definitely do
as this capturing so the change in
science definitely happens but this can
be very difficult yes this can be very
difficult to capture so I have 10
minutes left which means I will now rush
trailer remaining remaining slice but so
you could sort of say perhaps this is
some arbitrary arbitrary measure but you
think of a case so this task is a task
where you have radiographs and the
radiographs are here you're trying to
determine the age from a radiograph and
use the train you train in this case
with a train at inception on this
radiographs and the method that I told
you about before together back
propagation that doesn't change very
much you can visualize get at back
propagation with original model and then
you can visualize again with all of the
weights of the biases everything
visualizations so the point from this
work this work is we have another test
called the data randomization test that
was also gay also getting that this and
the point here is visual assessment of
justice heat maps can actually be very
deceiving because the methods are most
visually appealing necessarily there's
this really nice work from the last ICML
where the theoretically analyzed three
of this methods so they theoretically
analyze gradient guided by propagation
and a third one and they actually prove
that the guided by propagation method
essentially every construct I will now
rush drill out of the presentation so
recent work has also shown that there's
a potential fix for some of this sanity
checks that we proposed essentially the
fix makes it so that each dimension now
essentially is attributed to only one
output 1 output class and so one thing
you might be able to take one thing you
can take away from this is are the
sanity checks actually useful in some
sense the sanity checks essentially
capture whether you can rule out a
method they don't actually tell you
whether method is good so there's still
more work to be done in that area and
see recent work in this area and so
there's also some work that you can
attack this methods I will actually skip
some of this the up short of this is
that you can make it so there you can
make it so that it seems like the
prediction of a model doesn't change but
the explanation changes I don't know if
you can see this but top is an
explanation for a normal Network and
then you can essentially do analogues of
the adversarial attacks so the first
gradient sign method you can have the
first video that method for explanations
and in that case you can potentially
focus so the key takeaway from that part
is that we're just getting to this we're
just getting to the place where were
able to actually assess some of this
methods and there's a lot of recent work
that is like arguing with the religious
so you have something that you already
know is insane
and that they don't there's not a clear
frightening these methods there's no
clear definition there's a clear problem
statement for which they are the
solution and that's not even the
pretense of one and I think it takes
only a few minutes to sort of see how
they're there can't even be like you
make no assumptions about what the model
surface looks like give me any model
I'll give you any explanation you want
for any point if by explanation you
define it as just the way the gradient
points so in this world with that
completely agnostic about the model we
already know that it says that the
salience of math tells you nothing and
so on hey I think things of a really
nice paper that shows like kind of makes
this point but we also at risk kind of
of being in a world where we're trying
to combat insanity with sanity checks
and there's only so far you go they just
will come up with you know like if you
if you don't for someone to actually
make a statement about what the model is
doing
just so an argument of like what it's
not doing no I think I see your point
I think it's the if you're working in
this area and let's say you're coming up
with a new post off method I don't
necessarily think that person will agree
with your take that it's it's impossible
it's a very attractive view to say you
can train any money any model you want
and I will come in with a you're making
it seem like it's a sort of a crazy long
as they never say anything specific
enough for it to be a claim that you can
refute as long as it's not very
something that you can invalidate
there's no falsifiability then then you
know they just sort of immune to logic
yeah I mean I think coming to the
defense of some of this work I will say
there is a lot of work trying to you so
trying to go towards that that path so
you there's a lot of work and being as
one of this papers whether you're
defining metrics for which we can use to
train estimates so I will say right now
it seems like there's not like a like a
metric you can pin down to say this is
what the gradient should tell you about
this model or this is what does
explanation map should tell you about
this mod so we're not necessarily we
might not necessarily be there yet but
there might be a path towards that and
trying to especially because a lot of
those heat maps are very attract
very attractive from a visual
perspective and so even if there is no
metric they can still get wide of the
adoption and you might want to be
assessing them and sort of saying here
is
for short I think it's still an
interesting interesting well you're
saying just I think it's sort of their
danger right I don't think it's that
should be that's not a virtue would
advise that it's like they're but
they're supported by eye candy and you
know we can make many pretty pictures
that have no clear stated significance
but people find them visually attractive
we're getting a little sleepy we should
shadows that may be shut off line sounds
good so this part I will actually rush
through so okay cool so the motivation
so the second part of the talk is about
privacy and why you might and why local
explanations might be very tricky to
deal with from a privacy perspective so
let's say you're like I mentioned
earlier you're like a company and you've
developed this model proprietary model
that you think is very interesting and
you want to sort of sell it to other
people and it takes inputs and you give
outputs to some kind of API and then you
can also give explanations as well this
is one of the motivations and what is
actually interesting here is given the
predictions and the explanations is very
problematic from their standpoint so
there's this quote that I really like
Dork there's a book on differential
pairs
and it says overly accurate answers to
too many questions will destroy privacy
in spectacular and there's a work
there's a lot of work now there's shown
that when you have access to this
predictions or even explanations it's
very easy to recover the model with
explanation with this local explanations
actually it's easier you can do this
model recovery with fewer queries so
you're the coming from the perspective
of the company you might want to prevent
and I mentioned I mentioned this earlier
with a there are other techniques that
look at can I rank the training points
so that I can buy their effects on a
particular test loss so if you think
about this from the perspective of
privacy and this was mentioned also it
creates all paper we a few different
diverse examples and with enough
training points that I've shown you
essentially can capture most of the
information and the data in the
potentially proprietary data set that
was used to develop this proprietary law
and so these are potentially not
desirable from a privacy standpoint and
the privacy standpoint what you're
looking at here is differential privacy
so some of you might have heard about
see this captures the notion that if I
have let's say I have two neighboring
databases and they differ in one you can
think of it as one row the different one
row I don't want the output of my
algorithm my randomized algorithm to
change too much so because if it doesn't
change too much then if you try and do a
hypothesis test for whether this person
is in a database or the the power of
that test is not the reveal does not
reveal that so this is a very nice
definition of privacy and one of the
things that you can actually see that a
lot of these local explanations violates
in this case is you're offering an
explanation for particular data points
that's potentially even in your training
and so this this can be problematic from
a privacy standpoint and so can you
potentially use differential privacy in
some way to sort of stem this issue and
so there's this paper from 2016 that
sort of made SGD differentially private
version of the SGD and in short what you
do is you clip the gradients the per
example gradient of each input and then
you have noise so if you do this you can
train a differentially private CN n
the epsilon for differential privacy
captures how much privacy you have so
smaller epsilon is more a more private
model what I'm showing here is a so this
is a model on M Ness and each column are
different values of epsilon and the
upshot you should take from this as if
your so this is still ongoing work so
there's some more issues but if you
absolutely if your model is sufficiently
private the local explanations you're
releasing look like noise and they might
not necessarily even capture the
property that you want to which is you
want to provide information so to
conclude there are sort of two potential
trade-offs that I've sort of try to
communicate to you one is that he's very
it can be very difficult to assess some
of this explanation methods and we've
seen some recent work even beyond the
sanity checks that are trying to capture
this and another one is explanations are
very tricky especially local
explanations are very tricky to deal
with because in piracy context because
they reveal the model and this might be
undesirable perspective
and I think that's the
[Applause]
seems to be an excellent observer a lot
of overlap between all these explained
ability method at an adversarial
robustness and so on these two things
there's actually I did not talk about
any of that but there's a lot of work in
that line as well one strand is if I
train you might have seen this from some
train more robust models robust in the
sense that more adversary robust if you
look at some of those gradient maps they
look more interpretable he was
interprete Balazs so there's actually a
lot of work in that line and there's
some that said if you they give you like
a gradient map or some kind of map I can
produce
[Applause]